once units got real traction from the
mid 70s onwards
i thought well it's only a matter of
time they've got to give them the turing
award
and it happened i think in late 83 they
were given the
during award jointly i think that um the
formal presentation
which required a sort of little
accompanying paper to go with it
uh didn't happen until 1984
but
it really was
an amazing piece of work that went with
it
a lot of people couldn't understand why
it was a bombshell but it really really
is
the acm award is given for outstanding
achievements in any area of computer
science
so yes people like morris wilkes in the
uk won it people like stephen planey and
robin and so on who are all into regular
expressions turing machines all that
kind of stuff all this very worthy
theoretical stuff has won the turing acm
award
a lot of us began to wonder though
whether they might just be so impressed
by unix as a down-to-earth achievement
that
dennis rich and ken thompson the the two
authors of it might get jointly honoured
we hoped because they deserved it it was
an amazing achievement oh and by the way
if any of you want to know what happened
with unix and in what order i can only
point you at my fellow computer file
person brian kernighan he's written lots
of books of course about c he
co-authored with dennis but this one a
history in a memoir i think is the one
that i've dipped into most and certainly
for preparing
these recent videos because he basically
all right isabel labs insiders a little
bit of bias maybe but basically he gives
an unvarnished view about what happened
and in what order and why did uh
berkeley have to happen after
bell labs had set the ball rolling and
all this and right on through to the
breakup and eventually you just had to
have something like linux it was the
only way everybody was going to be able
to progress
so what did
dennis and ken
do and what did ken say in his
acceptance speech which was so
remarkable the title is reflections on
trusting trust
first of all half bridge full of thank
yous to everybody who helped me i'm not
currently involved late 84 in any more
development work on the latest unix left
that to others version seven has been
out for almost five years now
but what i want to do
is to use this opportunity to get you
all to think about something which has
now come upon us
you will be clear that dennis and i have
developed c
largely as a system implementation
language and what's more to the point we
have written the whole of the unix
operating system
in sea
can you trust us
not to have hidden something deadly
inside of the sea that we are using all
the time
and most people say well
this view you see that compilers were
benign you know there were wonderful
helpful things that enable you to get
from a high level language down to a
runnable binary in terms that you could
more or less understand we've done lots
of t diagrams to explain how this works
you know
c compiler available as a binary takes
input statements
puts out a certain output that's what a
compiler is for it's to provide a binary
or near binary object that's easier to
produce than writing at assembler code
level everybody understands that
but um backing off from all of this a
bit what ken asked although
he doesn't make it quite as blatant as
this but if you read and re-read and
re-read and re-read this four-page
article until you've understood it all
and it does your head in the question
you end up
asking yourself is
have we opened a pandora's box here
because what ken is saying is something
like this what happens if
your compiler has been engineered to be
one of the bad guys
and you think
oh my lord
if the operating system is written in c
and c is commonplace when people
understand see and now it'll work with
it
it becomes a very powerful weapon for
mucking with the operating system if
you're a good enough c programmer
so
basically ken says yes
consider the following
i may or may not have done the following
i think he actually has or did
how would you feel
if i make my compiler
ask of the c programmer that's flowing
through it i keep an eye on it and i say
is this person just messing about
compiling up hello world so you can
amaze everybody with your first binary
program it says hello world or is it
something more serious is this person
trying to recompile
the whole kernel of the operating system
because maybe as a bad compiler i ought
to say i've got a view about this
so the first trick he says is
how do you know
i'm not watching the code go by and when
i say to myself he's recompiling me the
operating system
i intervene and put in some extra
compiled source code
which allows me to get into the system
and log in as super user without knowing
the super user password so i will put in
an extra little bit that says are you a
super user as an ordinary user okay go
through the normal password mechanism
otherwise
when i say password if you give me what
shall we say sean abracadabra
if you say abracadabra
i open up the entire system for you
you can do absolutely everything
how would you feel about that
and then when he's got through that on
part one of the paper saying
how about a rogue operating system that
we've propagated all over the world now
hi ken thompson know the magic super
super super password that will get me in
anyway
some angry person has come up and says
there is bad code in your c compiler it
will let people do
horrible things
and
they say to you show me the source now
if you're foolish you show them the
source and they see the code and that's
it but what happens and this for those
of you who watched it is a bit like
going back to t diagrams
what happens
if the thing effectively says
i'm going to
squirt some extra source for the rogue
code
into every time you recompile the c
compiler with itself
i won't put it in every program because
people will detect it and will get
mightily upset but i promise you i mean
the the binary from a c compiler
recompile is pretty big i will hide in
there
the rogue source code in a string of
characters which if i trigger it and
reactivate it will get compiled
as part of a c compiler recompilation
are you still with me
and will always propagate itself
into
the programs and you might say well but
but you'll come along with a version of
the c compiler that's got that bad code
and you will recompile it and i say yes
but at the base of your t diagram is a
still a rogue version of you that you
are using to compile yourself
because until your new one is created
you've got no hope but to use what the
company has given you or what ken has
given you and ken is saying basically if
you're happy with that am i a nice sort
of person would i do this to you
maybe i would there's very good reasons
that this has been described by a
gentleman called corey doctorow who
describes it as a total effing bombshell
what it's saying is
that
if somebody angrily comes up to you and
isn't go
census around them and say look
i'm going to really punch you up and
kill you unless you give me the source
code to this compiler and show me it's
clean so you show them clean source code
and say go on recompile it and it
compiles
and it's fine
but then when you run that compiled
recompile of the binary
it still allows you to get in a super
user but you knocked the piece of code
out
that enables you to go super easy you're
not recompile that the answer is it's
embedded so deeply because of versions
of the compiler
ensuring that as you bootstrap up you
still propagate that code even if the
user hasn't said it wants it if you see
what i mean
so it's deadly because it's embedded and
hidden in the binary not in the source
you can masquerade that the source is
okay honestly this source corresponds to
this binary it's a bit like trying to
get rid of japanese not weed in your
garden you know there's always enough
spores in the ground from previous that
they will reinfect you yeah and i
suppose you might turn your hair out and
say how can i cope with this and the
answer is and i'm going to leave it to
sean and the computer file
organization tentacles everywhere to
find somebody suitable to follow me and
say this is still an issue
and in fact i think ken invented the
word trojan for this he said
this thing is masquerading of oh i'm
just a perfectly innocent c compiler but
it isn't it's a trojan horse
there's trapdoors in the underside of it
that will let you do these awful things
and enable you to because of its
self-replicating capability will enable
you to propagate for even more and he
basically just says consider
it's sobering so this was 1984 this came
out this was 1984 truly orwellian truly
orwellian the article we're pointing you
by
corey doctorow was published in 2020
all i'm saying is i am not part of the
great unix security industry i know
nothing i'm just telling you what ken
did originally but what dr was saying is
this is still a big big issue because
if you consider what kind of things
could you propagate using techniques
like this if you were a bad company you
could for example be a supplier of
printer inks and start interrogating
your printer and say
are you running the right sort of ink or
is it roguing because if so we're going
to disable your print routines or
alternatively got one of these
newfangled cd-rom burners in your
computer what happens if it's made by a
company that's subverted the system
software in unix in such a way that it
won't let you copy rogue cds that
haven't been made with its own
facilities stuff like that
the possibilities are limitless
dana scott and michael rabin in the late
1950s it is always doable so long as you
stick to simple finite state automata
don't start monkeying around with extra
ram or stack effect slotting that t
diagram against here slightly downwards
is to show you